[Applause]
oh
reagan you look so beautiful
you so do you i'm so happy to be back oh
my god i'm so happy to be back with you
and i feel like we both got sort of like
a falling collar memo and
the fact that reading is your passion
and the way that you read so
voraciously and you know it just really
inspired us and so we want to bring in
our correspondent and resident
book reviewer someone i started this
journey with
my partner in crime jonah larson
hey drew hi jonah how are you
i'm doing so good i haven't seen you for
a long time so i'm so glad to be back on
a show
talking about a book reagan you have a
book club
and jonah is just one of my favorite
readers which is why we wanted to do a
whole
reviewed by jonas series and we thought
reagan jonah jonah
reagan and we hooked you guys up with
some young viewers to discuss
your latest pick so tell everybody what
the book is
uh it's called it came from the sky by
chelsea sedodi
and it is such a good book um well
jonah uh how did it go when you talk to
other young ladies and gentlemen
it was really enjoyable because this
book has so many different elements and
different layers of it
and there's so many different
perspectives you can take based on one
story that you really have to read the
book to be able to understand what i'm
talking about
well let's see how the book club went
let's roll some clips
[Music]
so basically it came from the sky is
about two brothers who were doing a
science experiment and it went
totally wrong and they blamed it
on an alien invasion my favorite part of
the book
was the ending where jay quincy oswald
was exposed as a fraud
and the town 63 foot tall lava lamp
explode stephen what was your favorite
part of the book
my favorite part was when the two
brothers were exposed and had to tell
the police officer and the agent
about the hoax well my favorite part of
the story was the same as yours i
actually was when the lava lamp exploded
that was one was like
oh my god this is gonna happen next you
know that one just was like a page turn
gideon's dream job is to become an
engineer for nasa
ragan what's your dream job well i'm
actually kind of doing him right now
with acting but i'd also love to add
a few more things i'm obsessed with
horses so i would love to be a horse
trainer
i would love to be a marine biologist or
a vet oh wow i love
animals too so those supposed to make
great options now as a surprise for you
guys
we've invited the author of it came from
the sky chelsea sedona
bye hi guys how's it going
good it's amazing to meet you it's
awesome to meet all of you and i'm so
honored that you're talking about it
came from the sky today
we have some questions for you where did
you get your inspiration to write it
came from the sky
have you by any chance have had had any
extraterrestrial activity in your life
so i've been afraid of aliens since i
was a little kid
i i'm not sure why but i think i might
have
walked in on an episode of unsolved
mysteries
when i was like six i was wondering are
your characters based
on real people or did you just come up
with them on the spot
i don't like to make my characters too
much like real people because
i feel like when i've tried to do that i
go back
and reread the pages and it's just not
working what advice would you give
someone who wants to write a book most
of all
just write um but it's just one of those
things where the only way to get better
is to practice and practice and practice
well thank you chelsea very much for
stopping by and answering
our questions about it came from the sky
and
make sure to get your hands on a copy
that came from the sky by chelsea
siddotti
because it's available everywhere books
are sold and
back to you drew thank you jonah
reagan what was your biggest takeaway
from
the book i think my biggest takeaway was
probably to always tell the truth this
book
centers around as you may know like
a hoax these two brothers just created
literally
overnight and as the boys just continue
on with this lie
it's it like becomes like its
own it has a life of its own
and as the hoax like gets out of their
control
more and more people keep getting roped
in and
i would what i feel like is just always
tell the truth
everything you just said is so true so
astute
jonah what about you what was your
biggest takeaway from the book
well with the book like this you have to
have a couple main takeaways
one of them is don't keep others arms
length away
um open up to them and be more
open and like sometimes you just have to
be vulnerable and that really helps with
the relationships
but also of course be honest and they
have much bigger consequences
than if you just accept the consequence
right at the start and just admit to
starting the hooks
you're absolutely right you guys it has
a snowball effect
and what starts out this big can become
so
massive and lies grow
and everything you said is just so true
that it's better to just deal with it in
the moment
we have to be kind of strong brave and
responsible
and it's just a wonderful quality and i
think you guys
both really took it out of this book and
you're using it as a shining example of
what you can learn
from such a wonderful entertaining story
i'm
really moved by both of your reviews um
reagan thank you so much for bringing
your book club
to the show we're huge admirers of it
here
and jonah always thank you let's do this
again
as soon as possible we'll pick another
book and do this again
thank you so much thank you thank you
jonah we'll see you very soon and young
sheldon airs every thursday at 8 30 7 30
central
on cbs
[Music]
you